yeah welcome to a new game playing our
cowboy again who's in the house yeah the
Scandinavian yeah I don't really know no
much here this is some setup that is so
often employed an idol short this is
some what I know is playing this was d3
all the time hmm i know i could play 95
and take on f6 this is similar to the
Braunstein Larson and I haven't played
deform yeah I don't know isn't this a
good version of this maybe with Queen h5
as the possibility okay he prevented
that this is probably a good idea hmm
still um I don't know it looks like
maybe he can play Bishop hey I can play
Bishop g4 now maybe he should do that
try to provoke night a three and then
you change it I know this this looks a
bit a bit strange for Black Knight a
three are still moving the Queen again
looks looks so weird
hmm very interesting position
play h3 evo hehe needs to take Queen
takes
I guess along he can yeah probably
didn't do that anyway yeah yeah this is
why I was hesitating a bit i wasn't sure
that i really want that but it should be
should be okay for white he still has
some issues with this development and i
keep the Sun bishop on this strong
diagonal okay you can play six but I
always have this f5 ideas against that
long castles I can take f7 em in the
long run I need to play kingly one
anyway and this allows maybe you know
okay h3 hard to play without that and
now he's six a player 5 and start to
nibble at his pawns yes but I didn't
really believe in this with c4 and
bishops III I know the bishop but he's
like I have I have c5 and open up the
position it's not it's not a permanent
problem at the end the bishop sir should
count for something and then d4 d5 also
it's completely unclear where his King
should go long castles I don't know
looks disastrous
94 m maybe this is some an idea now one
day one but shouldn't be one oh yeah but
night age five
okay i want to make sure that the g file
opens maybe it was intending night age
52 g3 something like that and
now it's um at least clear that the G
file is really opening if it takes I
just recap show ya the idea would be
booked g1 and pile up on the G file
hmm difficult for black
I'm not sure that he M he needs to take
and maybe he can just ignore this for a
moment knight to e form okay yeah but i
first need to take him f6 is a possible
problem but what now even g4s sir not
without its points but opening the file
must be a must be good really check
yep just blast open the position must be
the right one everything's opening now
if it takes with the pawn I can take f5
and he doesn't want to take on g 5m k
group here Bishop f5 or why drop the age
is also not exactly bad winning it's not
about winning sorry yeah this one
winning the rook check check black
reasons yeah that seems like a rather
depressing position out of the opening
not not sure what went wrong there I can
I cannot really tell it's hard to say so
I don't know that's a hold it back here
I have no idea bishop this happen looks
fairly fairly strange but if this really
the problem I don't think so but this
would see 6 it looks strange okay yeah
and I don't like like the position much
but maybe I'm I'm overestimating things
iam this looks a tricky at least
yeah and this must be better for white
in some way he has a big problem with
his skin it's got no safe place for the
king and this Bishop only five is simply
excellent very hard to believe that
black could could be close to equal or
something yeah guess much of this game
is related to opening problems yeah
thanks for watching